In the late phases of Donald Trump's second
impeachment trial in which he was acquitted over
the weekend, details emerged about an absolutely
off the wall phone call between Donald Trump and
House Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy, which
culminated with McCarthy screaming at Trump.
Who the after you think you're talking to,
which is not typically the way people talk
to presidents, particularly when the president is
of the same party, both of the Republican Party.
The call happened on January 6th. And the reason
that McCarthy was on the phone with Donald Trump
in the first place was that he was begging Trump
to call off the rioters, explaining to Trump,
these are your supporters. This is terrible.
Call them off. Tell them to go home. And McCarthy
implored Trump, explaining the rioters were
breaking into his own office through windows.
And reportedly what set Kevin McCarthy off was
when Donald Trump, continuing to refuse to call
them off, said, Well, Kevin, I guess these people
are more upset about the election than you are.
That set McCarthy off into a tirade. Who then
said, who the hell do you think you're talking
to now? Layer one is that this is another
cartoonishly childish data point in the Trump
presidency. Trump unhinged, ignorant, absurd as a
participant in the American political system. But
the bigger takeaway is about the January 6th.
Right, because this call confirms that Donald
Trump obviously wasn't opposed to the rioting.
We already knew that. But he also wasn't just an
uninvolved observer who may have liked it. He was
being told as the president of the United States,
this is what these rioters are doing. These are
your supporters. And he was pleased when he says
to McCarthy, call them off. Now, these people,
they're more upset about the election results than
you are. That's a comment that's supportive of
the rioters. Trump believes the rioters are acting
correctly in relation to what Donald Trump feels
happened in the election, which is the big lie
that he repeated endlessly that it was stolen and
he really won. Trump's mindset was call them off.
Why would I call them off? They're angry for the
right reasons. They're doing the right things.
And then, of course, hours later, far too late to
have any impact. Trump put out that prerecorded
video half heartedly, saying it's time to go home
peacefully. But we love you and your great people,
and you're right to be upset. But it's time
to go home. Now, this all took place in the
midst of what Mike Pence when Mike Pence was in
physical danger at the Capitol on January 6th.
And of course, Trump knew about that and yet still
went on Twitter and denounced Mike Pence. Remember
when Trump tweeted, we have to now go into a
deleted tweet archive to get these because Trump's
Twitter account is banned, Trump saying Mike
Pence didn't have the courage to do. I'm sorry.
Yes. Trump said Pence didn't have the courage
to do what should have been done to protect our
country and our Constitution, giving states a
chance to certify a corrected set of facts, not
the fraudulent or inaccurate ones which they were
asked to previously certify. USA demands the truth
when Trump sent that. At that point, Trump knew
Pence was in danger and still tweeted that. Now,
once again, Kevin McCarthy is no angel in this.
Kevin McCarthy is still merely an amoral political
opportunist. How do we know that? Because just
weeks after this call where he said to Trump,
who the fuck do you think you're talking to?
Kevin McCarthy went down and that his pilgrimage
to Florida at Trump's Mar a Lago met with Trump
to recruit Trump's help in getting the House of
Representatives back in twenty twenty two.
McCarthy learned nothing despite everything
that happened on January 6th, flying down
to beg Trump for help in the next election.
McCarthy still standing by Trump. And so these
people deserve to be voted out. It's all just
at every point. It's just how how my affected by
this. On January 6th, protesters pro Trump rioters
were breaking into Kevin McCarthy's office. So
McCarthy said to Trump, you got to stop this.
And then Trump didn't. And so McCarthy was
furious. It's just how does it affect McCarthy?
And then two weeks pass that Trump is gone.
Democrats have the White House, Democrats
have the Senate, Democrats have the House, and
McCarthy wants to win it back. Well, if Trump
can help all fly down and do my pilgrimage, a pray
at the altar of Trump down in rural Largo, these
people are pathetic. They deserve to keep losing.
But it's up to us to make sure that they do.